foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
okay
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed it is Trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way extra points if you can sample Trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song please do it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
Dance
[Music]
15 times as opposed to Once
dumps dumps
dumps
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
passed from the election
what is going on here what is the what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
Alex Jones is now very very upset with
me look at that that is a freaking
Predator right there who thinks he's
smarter than you think he's better than
you and he's gonna beat you Pac-Man
never talked to the new world war
because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
clogged
clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
some bathrooms God bless the United
States thank you very much elements of
bathrooms
[Music]
throw every time I hear that theme song
ring it makes me wanna sing that catchy
thing
[Music]
[Music]
alone
[Music]
are you looking for a place to watch
some news where people don't yell while
wearing suits I know I know of a guy who
fits that bill of aggressive with
political will but David pectin shall
see your political knowledge sign up for
membership now for the bonus show that's
best in town who's the current president
of the United States
who's the current president well I guess
um I guess it's a it's a funny it's a
funny question
[Music]
foreign
well you tell me I mean is there a
president right now I guess
um well
I'd rather not answer that how's that
organization
[Music]
I've been growing with one huge heifer
all summer
it's time to pluck it
out
[Music]
all right well thank you for that very
exciting introduction welcome everybody
tonight is debate night once again I
have been keeping my promise for
everybody who is keeping track we are
streaming the debates what an explosive
debate we had last night involving Stacy
Abrams Brian Kemp and the libertarian
nut job as you may remember him and I
expect quite a solid debate today today
we go to the State of Florida and in
Florida we have incumbent Republican
senator Marco Rubio known as Little
Marco to some and congresswoman Val
demings yes indeed Val demings looking
to make the jump from the house over to
the Senate now
always I give you the truth as it is
rather than the truth as I might wish it
to be you all know that that is
something I do
and the truth as it is is that Val
demmings is currently behind by about an
average of Five Points in fact it's 4.7
points in the Real Clear Politics
average
[Music]
4.7
4.7 that means everyone must vote
everyone must vote as we stand by for
the debate just moments away now look at
these people in the chat saying she has
no shot
she doesn't have no shot
it's an uphill battle it's an uphill
battle that's the kind of defeatist
attitude Garrett
that I don't really like
I don't really like that Garrett now
it's not bandworthy or anything it's
just your opinion but come on guys that
she she could win
um that being said I do think it's
important to mention and we talked about
this on the podcast today the podcast by
the way available uh hours and hours ago
for our members at joinpakman.com the
Senate has shifted slightly in the
direction of Republicans and it pains me
to say that it is still the most likely
outcome that Democrats win
but if you look at this inflection point
from roughly mid-september it has been
declined decline decline and Democratic
odds in the Senate now at their lowest
point since
August 16th so that's not exactly what
you want
not exactly what you want Trump had no
shot and look what happened that's what
Cisco says via Super Chat exactly right
exactly right other super chats coming
in Jacob says David sir I emailed about
this but look at having Meg's Smacker on
the show her documentary is interesting
thanks for all you do all right all
emails are triaged but I am unable to
respond to and in some cases even
necessarily read all emails but rest
assured we have triage
and emails are being very very strongly
triaged let's listen a little bit to the
preview of this uh important debate
debate live from Palm Beach State uh
Lake Worth Campus it'll also be followed
by our post debate special that you
heard Jade mention with our exclusive
political analyst hey let's go live
inside the theater right now our
coverage does not stop here because
we're going to have live team coverage
throughout our evening shows if you
thought the coverage was stopping it is
not it's coming up in the next half hour
we're going to look at the preparations
that have been underway the past few
days along with what undecided voters
are hoping to hear from the candidates
tonight as we know anyone who's
undecided two and a half weeks before
the election those are clearly the
smartest and most clear thinking folks I
think we've experienced that like
remember when it was five days before
Trump versus Biden and you had undecided
voters definitely the people that really
show us the heart of America at this
point in time I don't even know if I'm
kidding
to be totally honest it's pretty
it's pretty full-on I'm not gonna lie
okay let's look at a few other things
that I have for y'all
um here is an interesting video sent to
be me by my colleague John here is an
anti-vaxx city councilman in where was
this hold on a second this is in Canada
but I want to be specific
where exactly was this
this was in
okay I don't know
this was somewhere in Canada
anybody know all right let's listen to
it
[Music]
please I'm sorry
okay yeah sure Michael Van Holst you're
City councilor oh yes you're the uh
right what getting into Boxster guy well
get [ __ ]
oh boy that is quite an aggressive
reaction
wow uh
uh certainly not uh
that's pretty good that's not bad
um not I not I'm not sure that that
would be my necessarily uh my my
Approach let me just hear that once more
yeah
right what getting into boxer guy well
get [ __ ]
the dejected look is really something
else I just wanted to make sure I heard
it guys all right so that's pretty
interesting here's a little something
else for you Kyle Rittenhouse now has a
YouTube channel
um as you can imagine it's going to be
very exciting he posted his welcome
yesterday he has 42 000 subscribers
let's take a look at the preview of the
new Kyle Rittenhouse YouTube channel
hey guys thank you guys for checking out
my YouTube channel I have some great
content that I look forward to making
for you guys thank you Brandon for
helping me get started for uh with you
and giving me some great advice so this
looks very interesting huh
this looks like it'll be really fun
very very uh pithy and uh uh
um funny little comments oh Kyle I don't
know if it's good advice yeah let's just
stay let's wait and see whether that's
good advice Kyle back to you it is
advice it's advice we don't know it's
advice but I don't know that I could say
that it's good advice Kyle let's find
out in episode two ladies and gentlemen
it's quite great yeah well it's actually
great I'm sure it's great we'll see
we'll see but oh my God was that did do
you get do you think that they went
through that before that little Exchange
well I don't know that it's good but it
doesn't say well I will say I think it's
good uh I don't know if it's great why
is the entire screen blue oh that was
weird advice yeah we'll see how the
channel goes it is advice it's advice we
don't know if it's quite great let's go
Brandon it is advice at the end of the
day
yeah we'll we'll see we'll see but you
guys can help him out by going ahead and
liking this video also why is
writtenhouse out of focus
[Laughter]
dear God everything going wrong not that
I care about this channel one way or the
other
they're both slightly out of focus but
like Rittenhouse is really out of focus
yo commenting posting the algorithm say
what kind of content that you want and
also of course by subscribing thank you
guys very much for continuing to support
me and I'll see you guys in the videos
to come yeah
so that'll be pretty interesting dear
God what is wrong with this country
um so that's the Kyle Rittenhouse
Channel forthcoming this was interesting
from what I read I have not pre-screened
this but again John sends me a bunch of
uh content for the live streams and this
seems pretty interesting Julian
assange's wife appears alongside
warmonger John Bolton
and Stella Assange calls Bolton the war
criminal which I sounds pretty good to
me let's listen another extradition
should go forward and when he gets to
the United States he'll get due process
here and I hope he gets at least 176
years in jail for what he did
well of course uh Ambassador Bolton is
kind of the
Nemesis of Julian he has during his time
for the Bush Administration later the
Trump Administration
sought to undermine the what was that
thing with someone's arms pop what is
that right there is that a move to
tighten the shot or what was he calling
for a side by side so that you could see
Bolton's reactions that was interesting
is that Piers Morgan I don't even know
who's doing that but that was it seems
like they're either calling for a
tighter shot or a side by side so you
could see Bolton's reaction to this
uh during his time for the Bush
Administration later the Trump
Administration
sought to undermine the international
legal system ensure that the U.S is not
under the international Criminal Court's
Jurisdiction and if it was Mr Bolton
might uh in fact be prosecuted under the
ICC he was one of the chief cheerleaders
of the Iraq War which Julian then
exposed through these Lakes so listen
I'm no fan of Julian Assange but she's
she's essentially correct here it's hard
to argue I mean Bolton was one of the
key warmongering architects of the Iraq
War that's absolutely without question
um he has a conflict of interest here
ambassador
well that's ridiculous I have an opinion
so does so does assange's wife I guess
we both get to speak them uh you know I
think that what she fears is being
brought to the United States and having
Assange put under trial if he's innocent
uh if you can she can at least show
reasonable doubt that he's not guilty
he'll go free what's she worried about I
guess what she's worried about is a fair
trial because it's pretty clear what the
attitude towards him is well let her say
a large number that's fine but
let let her say joy and Assange cannot
get a fair trial in America let her say
it okay well you cannot get a fair trial
in America because he is being
prosecuted under the Espionage Act and
he cannot bring a public interest
defense
pretty interesting pretty interesting I
mean again listen I I'm I'm no fan of
Assange but can he get a fair trial in
the United States probably not
um
yeah I mean just it's not obvious to me
that Assange could get a fair trial in
the United States let's let's put it
that way
uh okay I want to say thank you to Jason
sigmeyer and Carla manno for signing up
and gifting subscriptions on my websites
putting us at two out of a hundred also
want to say thank you to oh no to no one
else uh okay
um coupon code big voting 22 the goal is
100 if we get to 100 we will lock in yet
another debate stream later this week
um let's do
do we want to do voicemails right away I
guess I'll do a voicemail or two yeah
let's see what we've got as far as um as
far as voicemails go
um how about
let's see what the Eggman had to say
Dave I used to think Sports were just
barely acceptable when you and Pat talk
about the Patriots or a local New
England team you get all sportsy I don't
get too upset I know it's some liberal
some liberals like it okay this is why
sports are horrible okay when I was a
child Herschel Walker was a hero that
dude was the greatest uh football player
of all time ever was Herschel Walker
ever the best play I I don't remember at
all well you know I followed football
off and on for over 20 20 something
years
I don't remember Herschel Walker ever
being seen as like the best player does
anybody is was that actually the thing
someone who has followed the NFL more
closely than I have
sort of like saying like it seems to me
that it's saying like I remember when
like John Stockton was considered the
best player in the NBA it's like no it
wasn't when was that I don't remember
that
he was the best in college
he was never in the NFL that well that's
not true
anyway let's continue listen to this but
he knew that guy's name we loved him now
as an adult he's a racist horrible man
with CTE his brain is smashed up he
follows Trump he's destroying America if
he wins if he wins it's because of the
NFL and football as Sports being
popularized in America
if Herschel Walker wins he beats Warnock
and then they take control and then all
of a sudden America leads on this
massive downhill all because we love
football yeah all right well I
understand what the eggman's saying
Eggman is all wound up about it I
understand that
um let's see did I see any of Utah
Senate debate hilarious Utah First
competitive Senate race in 50 years ago
mcmonally I would love to see Evan
McMullen win that one and indeed
um I saw some of those clips and they
were pretty wild there was a message
here I did want to address Pac-Man why
not a fan of Assange please explain I've
talked about this before what I don't
like there's two there's two uh gripes I
have with Julian Assange one this entire
framing that Assange has had for over a
decade that Wikileaks is not political
and they don't calculate the timing of
their releases they don't choose what to
release and not to release
etc etc etc simply not true the timing
of a whole bunch of different releases
that they've done and the selective
release of information particularly
around the 2016 election Etc highly
political so the idea that we just
published documents it's it's put put
that in the toilet and flush it 10 to 15
times in addition to that
um
there have been I have to word this
carefully or people will flip out there
have been very credible links between
Assange and actors acting
in Russia's best interests against the
United States I'm not using the term
Russian agent or asset okay
which suggests to me that many of
assange's actions
around the 2016 election were calculated
to hurt Hillary Clinton and help Donald
Trump
and if you say you're just a
Clearinghouse for documents with no
political bias or interest whatsoever
the two are not compatible with each
other so those are those are my gripes
with uh with Julian Assange thank you to
Atomic yam for the twitch Prime
subscription folks if you have Amazon
Prime and you have not used your Twitch
Prime subscription this month yet Amazon
gives you a free twitch Prime
subscription every month consider using
it right now with our Channel these are
Bezos bucks it's quite literally taking
a few bucks out of Jeff Bezos pocket and
sending it to us so consider yourselves
invited
to Avail yourself of that functionality
let's see what else we have as far as
voicemails go
um
okay here's one from from Whitney
when the Spanish filters are wine
a flattened therefore it's French what
French wine
okay
here's the thing is that Spaniards
have nothing to compete with when it
comes to Spanish versus Mexican wine let
me read the story
okay now Whitney you're not reading the
articles on voicemail I'm sorry we're
just absolutely not doing that
um let's see what else we've got
uh David I'm calling you from Tampa I
see your show on Free Speech TV yeah now
I know that this is not your thing but
uh
many of the other uh
uh people on on Free Speech TV that have
shows I'm talking about zero hour and uh
other shows
they
seem to be siding with Russia blaming
the United States for Russia's invasion
of Ukraine where do you come down on
that don't know what shows you're
referring to I don't even have access to
Free Speech TV because I don't have
satellite television we love being on
Free Speech TV as far as what anybody
else is doing I couldn't tell you
there's also people on YouTube with
different opinions there's people on our
radio affiliates with different opinions
my view is that the country that decided
to invade Ukraine is responsible for
invading Ukraine that call me crazy guys
call me crazy okay Obama but that's my
perspective on that issue I want to say
thanks to El bandito bald
bert1234 and tzl Centurion for the
twitch Prime subscriptions we're in the
middle of a hype train on Twitch we have
not successfully completed a level 5
hype train in weeks ladies and gentlemen
but we might be able to do it today
let's look at a couple of other things
in the last minutes that we have before
uh what's happening here before today's
debate
um
okay the Hannity Walker thing I'm not
going to do right now oh by the way yeah
Val demings was an actual police officer
I know that this is going to really
maybe upset Herschel Walker
but Val demings really was a police
officer and uh we'll see if that
actually comes up today I think it'll be
very interesting
um let's see you know most of this stuff
I'm gonna get to tomorrow
so let's not do that now let's do a
couple more voicemails
uh yeah here we go
hey David I was just calling to ask you
a question and see if you were familiar
with uh Darren Beatty
if you'd ever be interested in doing an
interview with him thanks
I just Googled him and he's some kind of
conspiracy theorist I don't know maybe
depends what depends what the people
want
thanks to Jen here and tiger girl for
the twitch Prime subscriptions putting
us at eight for the day listen folks if
you're just joining us we are a viewer
and audience supported program and I
would love for you to get a membership
on my website this is so simple you go
to joinpakman.com and you sign up that's
all there is to it when you complete a
sign up this little blue bar fills
across the screen when it gets to a
hundred we all rejoice and we just give
things away
we just start give massive dumps giving
things away a way away and it's it's so
damn cheap that my lawyer and my
accountant and my coach are all saying
you can't do these uh discounts sir you
use the coupon code big voting 22 you
save massively you use the coupon code
Obama Obama and you save even more it's
so much that I can't even publish it
because people would laugh at me okay so
I can't do it thank you to Sergeant
Manjaro and tiger girl for two more
subscriptions and thank you to the very
powerful s press for dumping 50
subscriptions on Twitch chat which is
truly stunning stunning stuff
I very very much appreciate that there
is there is reporting unreliable
conspiracy reporting but reporting
nonetheless that attorney general
Garland is looking into the membership
discounts absolutely
what weapon do we have left against the
fear uncertainty and doubt on the right
now that humiliation doesn't even work
that has been depressing to observe over
time yeah they're almost reinvigorated
by being humiliated by the left it's
it's pretty sad thing
thanks to Jason sigmeyer for the website
membership you're number 61 absolutely
love it couple other uh voicemails
coming in here let's see what else we
have
uh
here we go
hey David tackling sir love the show
Curious question
is it fair to say that the honorary
badge is no better than uh you know like
a kid who goes on a you know Joy Ride
with a cop yeah no that's basically what
it is it's just like you go on a ride
along and you get handed a badge the
pilot on an airplane it hands you those
little wings that's basically what
Herschel Walker has it's it's pretty
embarrassing that he's making as big of
a deal out of it as he is it's it's bad
it's bad thanks to madman Mooney hatch
for short tiger girl and S Divine for
the twitch Prime subscriptions putting
us powerfully at 65. also thank you to
Lisa Rader for gifting a subscription on
my website that is number 66 today as we
are just moments away from the start of
this debate we'll see if we can squeeze
in uh another voicemail or two there are
a lot of interesting things unlistened
to in the voicemail box let's see what
else we have I want to make sure it's
something interesting
uh
no no no no
some of these are
some of these are a bit dumpy
um let's see
hi David uh I've been listening for a
few years
um a couple of things
um
with um
okay that one goes on with a lot of
pauses I want to say thank you to Bear
Grylls bear drills and a million to
choose from for the twitch Prime
subscriptions I've never seen this
before but apparently we're at a level 9
hype train
I've never seen that does it go higher
than that
thanks to cataclysm Rising for being new
member number 69 today with the twitch
Prime subscription very much appreciate
that as well we are down to the wire
here but let's just see if I can squeeze
in
a little more in terms of voicemails
hey David I I recently got back into a
bad habit of eating fast food veggie
burgers and fries and soda and it's the
first time in like a year so I gotta say
look it's this food is is mind-altering
it seems like you know the uh the greasy
salty food has like a calming effect and
then the sugar and the soda
is giving me a sugar high to stimulant
you know so it's like relaxing from the
greasiness and saltiness and the
heaviness of it it's all relaxing at the
same time as the sugar high
is is overloading me so I wondered what
you thought about that yeah I mean
listen I don't know anything
specifically about that sounds like a
question for a doctor but what I will
tell you is I have not eaten fast food
in decades and I have no interest in
going back and I do try to avoid highly
processed foods and you know mentioned a
veggie burger
I love a good you know house-made veggie
burger with like mushrooms and black
beans and the like
the
um you know a lot of those freezer
veggie burgers you're talking about a
highly processed food product with a lot
of additives and different things I stay
away from that stuff I try to avoid you
know uh you all know my peanut butter
rant peanut butter should be peanuts and
maybe salt if it's salted peanut butter
once you add in uh palm oil and molasses
and all these other things we're talking
about something else there okay we're
talking about something else so yeah I
don't eat burgers often but when I do
it's typically a burger that has one
ingredient and that ingredient is ground
beef that's you know exactly what you're
getting ideally from uh pasture-raised
beef would be the way to go all right
folks it is debate time
very very soon it's going to be debate
this is the pregnant pause we're we're
going on less than a minute you're
actually on now they seem to have no
idea that they're on this could be an
interesting minute
thanks to neilness robot laser party and
Flash gordon8 for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 72. also
thanks to Ian McKenzie who just signed
up on my website Ian thank you you're a
very special person and I really do
appreciate that
we are at a level 10 hype train on
Twitch is there such a thing as an 11
I don't know
but this will be a one-hour debate
incumbent Senator Marco Rubio on the
left
and Val deming's on the right
on stage right not politically she's on
the left politically
oh there's unlimited hype trains now
that's interesting I didn't know that
hoping for an Arizona debate-like moment
today
live from the campus of Palm Beach State
College in Lake Worth Beach Florida here
we go this is a wpbf-25 special
presentation
Senator Marco Rubio congresswoman Val
demings decision 2022 before you vote
U.S Senate debate made possible by
Florida press Association these proud
partners and Statewide sponsors
25 news anchor Todd McDermott here we go
Todd good evening and Welcome to our
audience from around the entire State
live on television streaming and
listening on NPR Florida this is
decision 2022 before you vote the U.S
Senate debate we are live from Duncan
theater on the Lake Worth Beach Campus
of Palm Beach State College Welcome to
our candidates congresswoman Val demings
and Senator Marco Rubio we are so
appreciative for your participation
tonight also joining me are panelists
Vicki sashary executive editor of
Florida Trend and Rick Christie
executive editor of the Palm Beach post
all three of us will be asking questions
of the candidates tonight the debate
Rules tonight each candidate gets 60
seconds to answer a question and 30
seconds to answer any follow-up
questions
rebuttals are 30 seconds in length and
at my discretion as your moderator wow
candidates when you see the yellow light
you have 15 seconds to finish the red
light means exactly what you think it
means and I'll remind you that it means
stop
because when that means you want the
coin toss earlier this week the first
question tonight goes to you
three weeks ago tomorrow hurricane Ian
hit Florida as one of the five most
powerful storms to make landfall in the
U.S
what federal action is needed starting
now
to protect Florida from sea levels
projected to rise a foot or more in less
than 30 years
while more frequent monster storms
threaten our lives and livelihoods
well thank you so much for that question
and let me say good evening to all of
you thank you to our panelists thank you
to Palm Beach State College it is an
honor for me to be here I stand on this
stage as a daughter of a maid and a
janitor who grew up in Florida
had the honor of serving as the police
chief in the house and now standing on
this stage
I grew up in Florida so I know all too
well the devastating effects that
hurricanes can cause on our state and
number one we have got to get serious
about climate change climate change is
real if we don't do something about it
then we're going to pay a terrible price
for it more intense storms like we've
seen as the waters in the ocean continue
to warm up more intense storms more
flooding more just Devastation as we've
seen with Ian I've toured the area and
I've toured Puerto Rico and seen what
Fiona did the federal government has got
to make sure that FEMA has the resources
that it needs to adequately respond but
we've got to get serious about climate
change thank you very much the same
questions you all repeat the question
um it was three weeks ago tomorrow
hurricaneian hit one of the five most
powerful hurricanes Deborah MC landfall
in our country Federal action starting
now
to protect Florida against sea level
rise projected up to a foot in less than
30 years while these monster storms just
continued to hit us and first of all I
also want to thank the college for
hosting us here tonight all of you for
being a part of it everyone for being
here in the audience this is important
I'm glad we have a chance to do it you
ask about the Hurricanes unfortunately
if you're in public service in Florida
you won't be here long before you're
dealing with hurricanes and we've done
so consistently throughout my time in
public service and unfortunately back in
2017 we had devastating storms 2018 as
well and now the devastation and
destruction that we're still calculating
I outlined last week a very specific
plan obviously it's preliminary on all
the sorts of things that we're going to
need help on these communities
immediately need emergency relief what's
happening for a lot of these cities and
counties is they have to spend a lot of
money up front money out of their
budgets they have to spend right now to
pay for these things and then they get
reimbursed not even engaged so that's
why I'm very proud that in 2017 and
again in 2018 I was able to get a
president Trump and the federal
government to fully reimburse our
counties for the help they needed but
we'll have to do more there'll be two
phases the first is emergency response
notice he's talking only about recovery
not about climate change these backfill
their needs and then they'll be the
long-term recovery and I'm very proud of
the fact that I was involved deeply in
all the long-term recovery efforts of
the last storms as well doesn't even
acknowledge climate change in his answer
I'm going to move on to question number
two and did not even acknowledge climate
change
Democrats passed the two trillion
American Rescue plan with no Republican
support
now inflation rates not seen in 40 years
show new no clear sign of abating
prices for just about everything housing
gasoline groceries are way up
a Federal Reserve Bank of San Francisco
analysis shows injecting trillions of
dollars in pandemic relief into this
economy caused up to three percent of
what is approaching a nine percent U.S
inflation rate
and it's worse in Florida
what can you do to help families now
well I think the first thing we have to
stop start doing is stop spending that
kind of money we had already done two
pandemic release this came on top of it
and right the two Trump ones were good
the Biden one was bad by other Democrat
economists you do this you're going to
fire up inflation so that's number one
number two is we've got to begin to
produce American oil again why are we
why are we begging Saudi Arabia for oil
why are we begging the U.S is producing
as much oil as ever a million barrels a
day Less on oil than we used to do just
a couple years ago we have you instead
we are depleting our reserves our our
oil reserves do not exist to win
midterms they exist to help this country
in an emergency or in the midst of a
storm what we cannot do is some of these
crazy policies that are coming from the
left that congresswoman demings are
supported you know she supported a plan
to put a what is a 10.25 tax per barrel
of oil which would have been 35 cents
per gallon more for everyone listening
here today we can't do that kind of
crazy stuff it only adds to the
inflation I think it begins by winning
this election and getting people like
that out of office
and that's time
congresswoman the same question you you
may answer but you have 60 seconds to
answer this question thank you so much
for that of course the senator who has
never run anything at all but his mouth
would know nothing about helping people
and being there for people when they are
in trouble no one planned the pandemic
but our response to it is everything
individuals were hurting families were
hurting businesses were hurting we
passed the cares act which the senator
supported there were some problems in
the cares act with the paycheck
protection program that you love to take
credit for some say it was poorly
written some say it didn't help the
people that it was supposed to didn't
save the jobs that it was supposed to
there was a way to fix the problems in
the PPP through the American Rescue plan
and help people that were in trouble but
you played politics Senator and you did
not do that your number one job is a
United States Senator is to protect the
health safety and well-being of the
American people you've been at it for 24
years
Senator Rubio whoa yeah a couple things
first of all we passed the paycheck
protection plan when Democrats were
sitting at home in the house they were
in their pajamas doing Zoom calls and we
were in the capital and we were working
in the capital to solve real problems
the paycheck Protection Program was a
bipartisan Victory if we hadn't put that
plan together we had to do it very
quickly and the capital that had no
staff very strong put it together in
three or four days bipartisan it got
unanimous support including the
congresswoman who voted I guess remotely
or whatever they did because the truth
of the matter is that if we hadn't done
that we would have had a meltdown we
would have had a meltdown in this
country we saved millions of small
businesses I am incredibly proud it is a
bipartisan achievement had we not done
it we would have had a depression in
this country the congresswoman likes to
talk about helping people she's never
passed a bill she's never passed a
single Bill she's been in Congress for
over half a decade she's never passed
the bill not PPP not anything not a
single Bill she's passed has ever become
law I'm proud of the fact we saved
millions of jobs I'm proud of the fact
we did it in a bipartisan way that's not
true I know the senator look and I'm
really disciplined appointed and you a
Marco Rubio because I don't I think
there was a time when you did not lie in
order to win
I don't know what happened to you you
know that it's not true my first term in
this in the United States house I passed
legislation to help Law Enforcement
Officers with mental health programs
your first term in the Senate you voted
to turn Medicare into basically to
abolish it and then turn it into an
underfunded voucher program and then you
gave the biggest tax break to The Riches
of the Rich and said you'd pay for it
because the Social Security and Medicare
no no this is important topic so number
one and we'll fact check it I'm going to
put it on my website now and all of you
can love the media loves the fact check
there was not a single federal law on
the books that she sponsored and got
passed not one I think she named two
post offices I've done that too but
she's not passed a single federal law
that's number one number two in terms of
the tax you know what we did in 2017 do
you know why today in Florida and across
the country working parents have a
double child tax credit from what they
used to have because I single-handedly
got it fast because I took on my own
party even the editorial boards that
direct there are two bills that were led
by demings which did pass the house and
I took on my own party The Wall Street
Journal even corporate interests so I'm
very proud of my record and the last
time
to that Congressman yes look the senator
has obviously resorted to lying cheating
and trying to steal but it's it's
embarrassing that you think that
honoring a person who is a hero
by name in a federal building after them
is nothing I think honoring a police
officer who was killed in the line of
duty is everything Senator it matters to
his family it matters to his community
it matters to his Department it matters
to me I think it's sad that it doesn't
really matter
both we need to move on I know but I
would not say it didn't matter I said
that that's all she's done that's all I
said that's all she's done
the next topic and the question goes to
you Senator all right great
in an August interview
Senator you said quote abortion is the
killing of an unborn human being
and that you do not believe the dignity
and the worth of human life is tied to
the circumstances of their conception
you've now signed on to fellow Senator
Lizzie Graham's bill for National
Abortion ban
my question to you specifically is if
re-elected
if your vote
can make a federal abortion ban the
moderator does seem disoriented the law
of the land
will you vote Yes number one I'm 100
pro-life because I but not because I
want to deny anyone the rights but
because I believe that innocent human
life is worthy of the protection of our
laws that said every Bill I've ever
sponsored on abortion every Bill I've
ever voted for has exceptions every one
of them does because that's what can
pass and that's what the majority of
people support now what was before us
today in Congress that you talk about
Lindsey Graham's bill that's a
four-month ban okay that is more lenient
than every country in Europe except for
two
the extremists on abortion in this
campaign is congresswoman demings she
supports no restrictions no limitations
of any kind she voted against the former
she's against a four-month man she voted
against a five-month ban she supports
taxpayer-funded abortion on demand for
any reason at any time up until the
moment of birth that's what she supports
that's the extreme position here I have
shown a willingness to work with people
to save unborn innocent human life she
opposes any limitation of any kind and
no one ever asks them about that guys
William Jennings
I said how gullible do you really think
Florida voters are
number one you have been clear that you
support no exceptions
even including rape and incest now as a
police detective who investigated cases
of rape and incest no Senator I don't
think it's okay for a 10 year old girl
to be raped and have to carry the seed
of her rapist no I don't think it's okay
for you to make decisions for women and
girls as a senator I think those
decisions are made between the woman her
family her daughter and her faith and to
sit over or to stand over there and say
that I support don't support abortions
up to the time of birth it's just a lie
but to help protect the life of the
mother which you've looked at that like
it was just well kind of a well that's
kind of a side issue the throwaway
Senator you know that you have said you
don't support any exceptions
number one the bill that she's attacking
me on has exceptions it has exceptions
that's the bill right now number two I
want to talk about extremes let me tell
you about extreme because you talk about
extreme here's extreme okay a child
that's born alive after a failed
abortion it happened 11 times in Florida
in 2017 it happened eight times in 2020
a child on a failed abortion born alive
and we had doctors in America that
refused to treat or provide medical care
to a child born alive and we tried to
pass a law that said that should be a
crime that's infanticide the abortion
failed the child was born alive and you
refused to treat it and she voted
against that that's how extreme she is
and she still will not tell you you
should ask her what limits on abortion
will you support congresswoman what we
know is that the senator supports no
exceptions he can make his mouth say
anything today he's good at that by the
way what day is it and what is Marco
Rubio saying I've said time and time
again and he knows it that I support a
woman's right to choose up to the time
of viability Senator I went before we go
yeah I want to get back to the original
question because I understand
ability I mean that's pretty clear you
have supported legislation that has
exceptions and that this particular bill
that Lindsey Graham is drafting you
signed on to does have that up to four
months but I asked you a specific
question that is this is a real debate
the chance in another six-year term to
vote for a federal abortion ban with no
exceptions would you vote Yes if it
would make it the law oh listen I've
already told people I don't believe that
the value of a human life has determined
that the circumstances right but the law
that can pass in this country I'm
interested in Saving human lives and
that's why every law that's out there
has exceptions including including the
one that that she's attacking me on has
exceptions every law I've ever passed is
exemptions we're never going to get a
vote on a law that doesn't have
exceptions because that's where the
majority of the American people are and
I respect and understand that and and
that's what I support but she's still
you haven't asked her no one here has
asked her she still won't answer what
specific limits she just said the limit
is the time of viability not after five
months and by the way and by the way on
the issue of exceptions I'm being
attacked on a bill that has exceptions
it's written right in there my name is
on that bill my name is on that bill
there's a reason why no bills were ever
introduced without excitability is what
between 21 and 24 weeks pass without
that in there and I understand and
recognize it and that's why I have
continued to support bills that have
exceptions but she supports No Limits
she just said the limit that is out of
the mainstream that is radical she
supports letting a doctor let an unborn
baby a born baby born alive and the
doctor doesn't have to treat it next
time another minute to you congresswoman
she explicitly said it Rubio has been
clear that he supports no exceptions
even in the cases of rape and incest he
said it time and time and time again but
what I can say to him and I can say to
Florida we are not going back Senator no
matter how obsessed you are with the
woman's body and her right to choose we
are not going back to a time where women
are treated like second-class citizens
or like property and I'll say it again
because obviously he didn't hear or he
doesn't want to I support a woman's
right to an abortion up to the time of
viability will she can you ask if you
support a 24-week ban will you support a
24-week bam because you didn't support a
20-week ban you didn't support to the
time of ability but when is that that's
the vague language they all give and
then they talk about the doctor and the
family let me tell you who else is in
that room the government is in that room
because she brought them in there she
wants the taxpayer to pay for that
abortion that's government involvement
not just to pay for that information
I'm going to ask that you both allow me
to move on Rubio is failing and failing
here
this next question comes from Rick
Christie
executive editor of the Palm Beach Post
good evening
congresswoman demmings uh just today in
New York Times Siena College poll shows
voters overwhelmingly believe American
democracy is under threat
a Washington Post analysis shows
election deniers are running for office
and 48 of 50 states
the New York Times poll also shows more
than two and five registered voters
including 37 percent of independent
voters are at least somewhat comfortable
and voting for a candidate who says they
don't accept the results of the 2020
election
will you accept results of the 2022
election
let me let me start here if I may
um my mother the maid and a janitor I've
worked long hard days
but I can never remember a time they did
not vote
if they are a car wasn't working they
would pay somebody a couple of dollars
to take them to the polls
why on Earth would we try to stop
them from voting
they were able to vote because of our
democracy the wonderful system of
government that we have no it is not
perfect
but our system of government is what
allows us to be here tonight
we have to do everything within our
power to uphold the Constitution protect
the rule of law and protect our
democracy and protect each person's
Republican Democrats and independents
right to vote that's what I did as a
police officer and a police chief I took
an oath that I would protect and serve
defend the Constitution not just for
people who looked like me or the
creatures of the rich but for all people
all right Congressman next time she
didn't answer same question goes to
Senator Rubio yeah at first I don't know
who the rich are because my dad was a
bartender backwards and my mom was my
dad was even poor she should have said
of course I'll accept the results
I've never denied an election ever
haven't ever said a direction I'm not
like Stacey Abrams in Georgia that
denied her election I've never denied an
election I think in Florida I think in
Florida we have great election laws but
I think elections have to have rules
and congresswoman Deming supported this
effort to have a federal takeover of
Elections what would that look like you
can't ask for ID you have to ask for ID
to get into her neighborhood where she
lives and that you have every right to
have that you but you can't ask for it
when they vote allow people to drive
around with a trunk full of absentee
ballots allowing people to basically
register on the an hour before the same
day of the election show up and vote and
inject chaos we have to have rules and
we have to reject chaos to be followed
Florida has good election laws and we
have a record turnout like they had
record turnout in Georgia which they
were out there calling some sort of
segregationist Jim Crow Bill no these
are rules these are rules that allow
people to have confidence that their
vote counted and their vote mattered
they're not suppressing anyone's vote
they are rules designed to make sure the
system works the way it's supposed to
let me just get you on record here that
you will support the results of the 2022
election we have great laws in Florida
absolutely but will you sure because I'm
going to win I look forward to
supporting that but because
because I'm going to win no matter what
the outcome is I'll support it because
Florida has good laws they're not crazy
in these other places I want to go to
Vicki sachary from Florida Trends
magazine uh I don't think we gave
congresswoman demings that I believe
we're going to move we're going to move
on here to the next question and that's
Vicky's question okay whoa six
homeowners insurance companies wow that
moderator is not happy with what's going
on or that that panelist wow Florida
taxpayer-backed Citizens property
insurance they're now insuring more than
one million properties in the state and
Counting
as the insurer of Last Resort the
collapse of citizens would be a
catastrophe for Floridians what should
be done on the federal level to avoid
this
what was the question for him what
Senator Rubio I'm sorry okay so number
obviously this is a state issue but
here's a couple things that I would say
the first the flood insurance program
which is critical a lot of the people
that were harmed in the storm hurt in
the storm would have flood insurance not
only we have to go back and reauthorize
it every year we shouldn't have to keep
going back every year should be
permanent we should also reform the
system Florida actually pays more into
the flood program than it takes out you
talk about the property insurance issue
it is a state issue the federal
government you don't want the federal
government involved in property
insurance believe me okay but I will say
this to you we are I believe the number
is about eight or nine percent of the
roof claims in America we are 83 percent
of the roof lawsuits in America and so
what's happening to these insurers is
the cost of litigation they're saying
I'm out I'm out in Florida and look I
worry about it my property insurance is
up at the end of this year and other
people should be worried about it
because when your property insurance
goes up if you can't afford it or you
don't have it the mortgage company will
force place you and your mortgage could
double so we are facing a looming crisis
I think it's something the state has to
get their arms around but I am certainly
in favor of not just reauthorizing but
reforming the flood program separate
from the wind the flood program and
reforming it so that Florida's treated
fairly congresswoman you have 60 seconds
to answer this same question would you
like it repeated no I don't but thank
you so much
Vicky let me tell you as the senator
works very hard to say it is a state
issue
that doesn't mean at the federal level
we should not care about
what citizens in Florida are going
through and try to do something about it
Marco Rubio has spent more time at the
state level than certainly any person on
this stage so it's interesting to hear
him say oh that's such a state issue
well what in the heck did he do about it
when he was the speaker of the house or
servant he's been in elected office
since 1998. and insurance in Florida has
tripled and people are suffering I sent
a letter to Governor DeSantis saying yes
I know it's a state issue but how can we
work together to lower the cost of
property insurance for Floridians
because people are suffering we got to
prepare for the next hurricane are we
going to wait and do nothing I asked him
to call a special legislative session to
talks solely about this issue we have
got together from congresswoman I want
to give you 30 seconds to rebut well
first of all when I was in the state
legislature if we want to go back to
that we actually had a special session
and we passed a reform you know who the
governor was at the time Charlie Christ
you're a gubernatorial candidate I think
you've endorsed him so you should ask
him if it didn't work but we certainly
supported it and we certainly made it
happen so that's number one number two I
would say that trust me when I tell you
guys trust me when I tell you a federal
government that struggles to deliver the
mail in a regular and consistent basis
in parts of this country you don't want
them in charge of yet because it's been
deliberately kneecapped Marco country
that's asking the federal government to
take over their property insurance
do I care about the issue yeah I care
about the issue I'm about to pay eight
or nine thousand dollars a year more
that's the 30 seconds thank you Senator
we're gonna move on to the next question
this question goes to you senator
five days ago the Parkland Mass shooter
who killed 17 people at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School avoided the death
penalty
that shooter and the killer took eight
lives in an Indiana FedEx facility last
year were both 19 years old
when they killed the killers in this
year's mass shootings in Buffalo and
Uvalde Texas were both 18.
all use legally purchased AR style
rifles
in the nationally televised CNN Town
Hall three days after the Parkland
Massacre
you should quote if you were 18 years of
age you should not be able to buy a
rifle I will support a law that takes
that right away would you still support
that federal law now let me tell you why
that law doesn't work and why that
proposal doesn't work we had a shooter
last Thursday tragic and I was very
wrong where did he get the gun he didn't
get it from a gun show he certainly
didn't buy it he's 15 years of age we've
had shootings in the state pulse was a
terrorist attack a licensed security
guard with a permit to carry firearms
extensive background check the guy in
Parkland this killer everybody knew who
it was even before they announced who
the person was everybody in the
community knew who it was because this
guy had long problems he'd been acting
up for a long time everybody knew it and
here's what happened the sheriff did
nothing about it the school district did
nothing about it because they didn't
want to arrest kids and fell through the
cracks even the FBI cracks it fell
through so that's why one of the first
things I did when I got back to
Washington is I sponsored a bipartisan
red flag law styled after Florida not
the crazy one they just passed a real
red flag law that would allow the police
department to go before a judge and
remove your guns if they can prove that
you are a danger the one they passed
allows some co-workers that doesn't like
you to go to some liberal judge and take
away your second amendment rights so I
think the solution of this problem is to
identify these people that are acting
this way and stop them before they stop
you here Senator but before I go to
congressman I want to make sure that I
understand that what you said in 2018 is
not what you believe is the solution
today 18 or 19 or 20 years old 15 year
old just got a gun got a shotgun but
that's one case I just want to make sure
there's more than one case but the one
in Connecticut also involved we could do
this all night but I want to make sure
that you don't support that anymore it
is it is important denying the right to
buy it is not going to keep them from
dude you won't just say I was wrong why
are these kids why are these people
going out there assisting people this is
this because this is the same arguments
and they don't kill everyone I
understand but when I go to college one
demings for 60 seconds
you know people who are
the families of
victims of gun violence just heard that
and they're asking themselves what in
the hell did he just say um
Senator you use the the Pulse Nightclub
shooting as your inspiration
to run again
for the senate in 2016. Parkland uh
pulse is in my district
and yet you've done nothing
nothing
to help address gun violence and get
dangerous weapons out of the hands of
dangerous people
Florida after Parkland after you made
promises that you had no intentions on
keeping to the parents of Parkland
Florida passed legislation raising the
age
to have an assault weapon pass red flag
laws that we've seen 7 000 plus
instances where they've been used now
to our primary responsibility is the
safety of Floridians and Senator 24
years in elected office and you have not
yet risen to that occasion and they when
asked about it you say something that
makes no sense all right Congressman
thank you Senator 32nd rebuttal from you
yeah what makes no sense is that we're
going to actually pass laws Rubio seems
to resent even having to be there like
he's he's sort of acting like this is
all beneath him Americans have a Second
Amendment right to protect themselves
they have and and these killers that are
out there if they're intent on killing
as they are they have found multiple
ways to get a hold of weapons and cause
mass destruction just the other day he
used the shotgun which would have been
covered by any of these restrictions I
have a bipartisan red flag law sponsored
with Senator Jack Reed but the problem
is that the leftists in the in the
Senate and in the house like Senator
like congresswoman demons are against it
the California red flag law that allows
your co-worker has a grudge against you
and go to a judge and take away your gun
because that'll never support that's a
30 I mean Overlook senator academics
we're going to just blow by there
thank you look every time we talk about
responsible gun ownership and resp and
legislation that could help protect
lives you pull the Second Amendment out
my father was a gun owner
has nothing to do with the Second
Amendment this is about taking dangerous
guns out of the hands of dangerous
people and the overwhelming majority of
people in our nation want us to do just
that how long will you watch people
being gunned down in first grade fourth
grade high school college Church
synagogue or grocery store a movie
theater a mall and a nightclub
congressman and do nothing that is time
I want to give you 30 more seconds
Senator wow well everything she's for
would have done nothing to stop any of
these shootings every one of these
shooters would have passed to pass the
background check that she keeps
insisting on no one here is in favor of
of mass shootings and violence and
that's why she says we did nothing
that's not accurate the truth today you
go to the department Homeland Security
website and there's a Clearinghouse
she's going to mock it she shouldn't
because the idea came from a Parkland
father and there's a clearing house
there that basically tells schools for
example this is what works for safety
and this is what doesn't and we got that
put in there you know who's trying to
take that down the Biden administration
because they say that to have a school
safety Clearinghouse is discriminatory
against minority students fine
but Senator Rubio thought that he could
reduce this very critical issue to
supporting a Clearinghouse on the
homeland security website and he thought
he would get a pass oh my God for the
mass shootings that we've had in our
state and doing nothing
significant to do anything about it your
primary responsibility Senator is to
protect the safety of the people that
you represent we just passed the bill
they wanted and there was a shooting a
week later I don't know the week after
that why did we just stop arresting
murderers
citizens
issue and in this half of this debate
we've reached halftime and it is brief
so everybody stay tuned we have many
more issues to get to your watching
decision 2022 the U.S Senate debate for
Florida
wow I have not seen any of the debates
so far this season
be this lopsided I mean Rubio's got to
be regretting even agreeing to this it's
so brutal what is happening right now
he seems disoriented he seems almost
Punch-Drunk and it's not like Val
demmings is perfect here
um but this is this is just crazy
uh Bad Bunny is I guess doing at the
halftime show for the debate oh no it's
just a commercial okay
um the moderators are so the moderator
is bad the panelists seem not thrilled
with how the moderator is running this
thing
unbelievable stuff uh thanks to
everybody who's watching Jordan says via
Super Chat Rubio visibly uh panicking
David sir thank you for streaming love
watching these with you says Austin
thanks to everybody who's been dumping
in memberships and twitch Subs during
this this is something else that we are
seeing here and demings is currently
down by about four and a half points it
would be great if this debate can turn
it around it really would uh
we will see we will see about another 25
minutes of this debate and it is uh I I
mean I I'm stunned by how lopsided this
is I really am
um
Rubio seems both resentful of having to
be there bored
but also unable to substantively refute
the things that Val demings is saying
now okay Val demings has decided that
she's going to directly address him and
go after some people were saying in the
chat that's not a good strategy it seems
to be working okay so far and remember
she's trying to come from behind
uh so you've got to try something Steven
says at least Rubio hasn't yet said the
word regime yes no that's true has not
yet uh has not yet said that what is the
coupon code today people are asking well
the coupon code is obviously Obama Obama
that is the coupon code at
joinpakman.com
um yeah it's rare usually the debates
don't have a break this one did
welcome back to our debate for U.S
Senate here in the State of Florida I
think we all agree we touched on a lot
of very important emotional issues and
there are many more in this half hour
Senator Ruby I want to direct this next
question to you
this week the bite Administration
changed its policy now Venezuelans who
crossed the southern border will be sent
back to Mexico and banned from ever
applying for asylum in this country
do you support that what's wrong with
them just instituted Trump's return to
Mexico policy there's more to it
congresswoman Deming says that what's
happening at the border is nothing
unusual we have 5 000 people a day
crossing the border you know how many
people have entered our country
illegally since Joe Biden took over as
president five million you know how many
have entered this country just in the
last 12 months 2 million 80 of them on
the terror watch list at least according
to the most generous numbers at least
one percent meaning twenty thousand was
serious criminal violations in their
record no country in the world I
sympathy no one has done more on the
issue of Venezuela than I have and Cuba
and Nicaragua I sympathize deeply with
everything these people are facing and I
blame Maduro for that but there's no
country in the world that can tolerate
or permit or afford
5 000 people a day arriving at your
border saying the magic words and
getting Asylum and she says that's not a
problem she says there's nothing unusual
about it this cannot continue it has to
be fixed he needs not just to do that
that needs to happen with everyone
that's trying to come across or we're
going to have 10 000 people a day coming
and we can't afford no country in the
world can tolerate that that's time
Congressman I want to give you this is
not a rebuttal this is the entire 60
seconds as we continue this discussion
and I want to ask you about Solutions
specifically what Solutions do you have
for solving the crisis at our Southern
border we are a nation of laws have
enforced them for 27 years despite what
the senator wants you to believe
he's living in fantasy land I've
enforced them
and we need to make sure that the men
and women at the borders have the
resources that they need
I am a fan of boots on the ground let's
have more boots on the ground but let's
also hire more processes so that we can
separate those who need to be arrested
from those who are seeking Asylum We're
a nation of laws but we also we have to
enforce the law but we also obey the law
that says people who are in trouble can
seek asylum in this country and so more
boots on the ground more technology more
processors less secure our border the
senator likes to talk about open borders
it's almost an insult to the men and
women who are there securing the Border
but let's get more agents to help at the
border we can do this if I may respond
to that number one the only one who's
insulted the people working the Border
are Joe Biden and Democrats who accuse
them of whipping Haitian migrants and
that turned out not to be true number
two she opposed the Border woman she
supported this thing called The People's
budget which I call the crazy people's
budget because they had a bunch of crazy
stuff in it even Charlie Chris voted
against it and that absolutely zeroed
out and banned border funding she talks
about more processors I want you to
think about what that means what that
means is now when someone crosses the
Border turns himself in claims Asylum
they're usually held on detention for
two to three days while they process it
what she's arguing is let's hire more
processor so we can get them through
faster so we can push people through
instead of one day to three days
attention
this can't continue we have to stop
let's ask the congressman to respond to
that you have 30 seconds congresswoman
if we have more processes and they don't
meet the stat standard for Asylum
Seekers you send them back
yes we need to secure our border more I
think we can do that with technology
more boots on the ground and more people
to process those who need to be turned
back those who are breaking the law from
those who are Asylum Seekers Senator
enforce the law but also obey the law
which boots does she want on the ground
she was against National Guard
deployment they demonized the border
patrol and they talk about processors
they're talking about well your party
demonize the you have and your party has
congresswoman absolutely true and let me
tell you something else that they've
done look here's the other things
anything to win senator they talk about
more processors okay so people everybody
the Biden Administration
I want to move on to the next thing
I'm forced to move on at this time
people do you think people are the next
question is going to come from Vicki
cescery from Florida Trends magazine
Vicki
representative demings last year you
backed legislation that increased Social
Security benefits and would require
Highway journals to pay more in Social
Security taxes why should Congress raise
taxes to pay for a broken system
well number one we have to think what
the about what the promise of Social
Security was
it was to keep our seniors out of
poverty and you know being an elected
office in the critical position of being
a United States Senate senator
it is about making choices to protect
people
I believe that we've got to do
everything within our power to protect
those who have had to go to work every
day and deserve to be able to retire
with dignity and respect governing is
about priorities and Social Security and
protecting it is a priority for me I'm
not going to sacrifice this and we need
to do what we need to do whatever that
is to protect it we can do that
and follow-up question for Senator Rubio
Florida's Junior Senator Rick Scott
proposed 11-point plan to rescue America
requires quote all federal legislation
to sunset in five years if a law is
worth keeping Congress can pass it again
Senator Scott says that includes
Medicare Social Security and VA benefits
Bonkers do you support putting these
Federal entitlements on a chopping block
every five years no and that's not my
plan that Senator Scott he's doing a
great job he's not very shy you should
ask him he's more than happy to talk to
you about his plan I can tell you on the
other hand if you want to talk about
radical plans congresswoman demon
supported a radical plan I already
mentioned earlier the people's budget
let me tell you the other gems in that
budget it raised nine trillion dollars
in taxes nine trillion dollars in taxes
I already told you about the 10.25 tax
on a barrel of of oil which would have
been a 35 increase on the gas prices
you're already paying right now let me
tell you what else it did it zeroed out
the war on terror it took a billion
dollars out of the Pentagon this is
crazy stuff and that's not a plan she
voted for it she didn't just put her
name on it she actually voted for the
crazy people's budget a socialist budget
she voted for it I don't even know if
she remembers I've seen the Socialist
budget well you voted for the people's
budget and it's a socialist budget so
especially when I tell you that any
budget that zeroes out the war on
Terrace takes a billion a trillion
dollars out of the Pentagon okay raises
taxes by eight billion eight trillion
dollars on working Americans
Senator you're repeating yourself again
we've seen this show before
socialist socialists crazy
Marxist silly that must be on your list
for your talking points
um the bottom line is you said that Rick
Scott's plan it's good to have good
ideas you did not say that you did not
support it I hear you saying that
tonight but when you were first asked
about his plan you said I think it's
good to have good ideas you remember
that congresswoman Senator you can
respond yeah that's Rick Scott's plan he
can defend it he can talk about it her
name is
people's budget the people's budget had
her name on she was not just a
co-sponsor two years in a row she voted
for it
there's never been a vote on Rick
Scott's body does she voted for this
thing eight trillion dollars in taxes
eight or nine trillion I can't remember
at this point what's another trillion
right
um You talk about all the other things
that were in there a 10.25 tax on a
barrel of oil so that your prices go up
by 35 cents I don't know what word you
prefer socialist Marxist crazy I don't
know I'm open to suggestions
he's talking about the barrel of oil
again
so yeah everyone's talking about the
barrel oil these days look you've been
in elected office in Florida for 24
years and what we have been left with is
skyrocketing property insurance lack of
affordable housing
Health Care in the corner of the roof we
haven't expanded medicaid people are
hurting and you know what Senator when I
talk to your voters around the state you
know what they say they don't know what
you stand for all right congresswoman
that that's your time and I'm going to
move on to the next we've spent a lot of
time I thank you both I know this was
had a lot to to discuss but let's move
on
congresswoman this is going to go first
to you
President Biden says the world's closer
to nuclear Armageddon than any time
since the Cuban Missile Crisis exactly
60 years ago this month
three times in the last week Vladimir
Putin has ordered Russian missile
attacks on Ukrainian cities targeting
and killing civilians
if Russia next fires a limited range
tactical Nuclear device at Ukraine
or strikes a NATO Ally like Poland even
with a conventional weapon what's the
correct response by the Biden White
House in NATO
well we have to hold those who are not
our friends accountable
and Senator that does include Russia
it's not just China
Russia has attacked our Ukraine what
they or our friend Ukraine what they
thought was going to be over in a few
days as you know has been going on for
almost a year we have to continue to
support Ukraine and our NATO allies
of course we've got a whole Russia
accountable we always
use diplomacy around the NATO table we
cannot afford to have a nuclear attack
and the United States has to do
everything in its power to prevent that
from happening
Senator same question to you well on the
first point about Vladimir Putin I was
against Vladimir Putin before being
against Vladimir Putin was cool
I mean and and I remember that very well
because Hillary Clinton and the Obama
Administration tried to reset relations
I'm not sure if the president had to do
it over again he would choose the words
Armageddon or Cuban Missile Crisis but
there's no doubt about this Vladimir
Putin is losing this war and if he loses
the war he'll lose his position and you
know I don't think the retirement plan
for former
Russian dictator presidents is a very
good one so I think he's very concerned
about that so I do think we have to be
very wary and I've warned about this
from the beginning about what he might
do to escalate one is the use of a
tactical weapon which is not a strategic
weapon we're not talking about launching
a missile against Chicago or New York
but we are talking about the use of
artillery shells and short-range
missiles in the battlefield which would
be unprecedented and I think the
response to that has to be a unified
response that perhaps takes out what it
is that launched those and where those
was launched from I think the likelier
scenario and the one that really is
concerning is that he would attack for
example an airport in Poland at that
point NATO would have to come together
and decide whether they're going to
invoke Article Five and the United
States needs to live up to its NATO
commitments let me ask the congresswoman
to that point the NATO response we know
what the NATO Charter says Poland's
attacked as the Senator's scenario says
perhaps the airport
what is the response
from the United States as well as NATO
we have to do everything within our
power to protect our NATO allies
everything within our power if if Poland
is attacked then there has to be an
immediate response and I believe between
our military and the Department of
Defense and our experts and our
intelligence Community Based on the
Intelligence on the ground
I believe that that response will be
sufficient and Swift but we got to leave
it in the hands of the people who are
there and the people who are involved in
this every day with the ultimate goal
of keeping America safe and keeping our
allies our NATO friends safe
all right Senator I have 30 more seconds
well just to add I think the response
needs to be proportional and that what I
mean by that is that the NATO alliance
will have to meet and this can't be
unilateral the NATO alliance will have
to meet and decide what is a
proportional response and that would
depend on the nature they're basically
both saying the same thing I'd response
not simply a U.S one that's what's most
critical here it's not anything at our
disposal because we're not talking about
the use of strategic weapons or starting
World War III but there needs to be one
I would argue to you tonight that
they've already attacked NATO because
the north stream pipeline underwater
that supplies Germany from Russia has
been bombed it was bombed and everyone's
wondering I saw a news report well
they're saying Russia may have done it
well who else did it Senator Belgium
Senator can you wrap this up for 10
seconds I need to move on all right
we're good yep I want to go back to Rick
Christy from the Palm Beach Post Rick
horrible moderator uh congresswoman
doings uh Senator Rubio is called
Democrats attempts to pass a new federal
voting rights law an effort to quote Ram
through an election law to make sure you
never lose power to make it easier for
Democrats to win why are new federal
protections of voting rights needed
well let me say this uh I'm not the
person standing on the stage who
supports suppressing the right to vote
look I can think about the words of my
friend and former colleague John Lewis
who said the right to vote is precious
that is almost sacred
and the senator thinks that we should
leave that up to the states
well we try that with voting rights and
we know the Bad actors who did some
ungodly things to stop people from
voting
so we should not just protect the right
for a few people or the privileged few
we should protect voting rights for
everyone and we need a federal law to
keep everybody accountable the John
Lewis voting rights advancement Act is
sitting in the Senate right now waiting
for a vote the freedom to vote at which
will help protect the right to vote for
all people is sitting in the Senate
right now waiting for a vote that is our
duty and responsibility to allow the
people to vote that's time Rick I know
you have another question uh this
question is for you Senator Rubio in
January you wrote in the Federalist that
Democrats pushed for voting rights is
about again quote exaggerated problems
and imaginary fears unquote can you give
us specifics on what you mean by that
it's never been easier to vote it's
never been easier to vote in Florida you
can now vote by mail for any reason you
can vote for example 10 days before the
election you can vote on Election Day in
Georgia which they claim to be the place
that was suppressing all the votes you
had a record African-American voter
turnout to compare what's happening now
for the Jim Crow era where people are
literally murdered where people were
forced to take poll taxes and pay poll
taxes and literacy tests what are we
talking about here we're talking about
this we're talking about number one when
you go vote you show an ID I have been a
Hispanic man my entire life I'm a
minority I've never felt like producing
an ID disadvantages my ability to vote
everyone has an ID you can't even check
into a hotel you can't buy Sudafed at
Walgreens without an ID that's number
one number two is you can't collect a
bunch of ballots harvesting a ballots
cars showing up with tons of ballots
sitting in the trunk of a car things
like that that they want to force down
the throat of every state in the country
we don't need that federal law imposed
on every state Florida has very good
election laws and other states have very
good election laws and the states that
don't have very good election laws are
the states that actually have gone in
the opposite direction of weakening
security for the ballot all right
Senator thank you Congressman I want to
go back to you for 60 seconds Florida
has an uh election law police force
and if the laws are so wonderful
why what's the need for that Florida
also eliminated the number of drop boxes
from 2020.
why do that particularly in certain
areas Senator your job is to make sure
that every person votes the ones who may
vote for you and the ones who may not
vote for you that is your responsibility
so if it's so perfect why the
adjustments we need to hold States
accountable to make sure every person
although that scares the senator to
death has the right the precious right
to cast their vote Senator yeah I'm
trying to suppress the vote and I'm
wasting a lot of money telling people to
go out and vote because that's what my
campaign has been all about number two
I've never supported any support you
tell everyone to vote but you
strategically close polling place I mean
come on everybody knows how this works
standard by which we judge whether
people are being allowed to vote or not
we didn't have dropboxes 10 years ago we
didn't have drop boxes in 2016 when the
congresswoman was first elected to
congress we didn't have drop boxes in
night in 2012 when Barack Obama won the
State of Florida running for president
that's a method of voting that doesn't
Advantage one group or another there's
danger involved in drop boxes people
need to think about it okay imagine
someone decides oh there's a Dropbox I'm
just going to put some explosive in it
and blow it up and burn all those
ballots and now those votes don't count
at all okay there is there's something
the slot is like so thin on these drop
boxes that I've seen like I don't know
how you put a bomb in there but the
other is there has to be public
confidence the public has to believe
that the elections were fair and
balanced and that's what I've always
been in favor of but what they want is a
federal takeover of the elections I do
not want a federal takeover of our
election system I oppose it that's time
Senator congresswoman that's nonsense
okay
that we want a federal takeover
we
pass
the Voting Rights advancement act in the
House of Representatives because of the
unbelievable voter suppression efforts
that were going on by the senator and
his party
which voters
vote that's nonsense what he just said
we want every person to vote and Senator
we've been busy to encouraging people it
doesn't threaten me it doesn't scare me
Congress will make the people vote and
that's time I want to move on to another
issue we are coming close to the debate
I want to make sure you both get all
your time for closing statements right
this is going to go to you first
congresswoman
the bide National Security plan
identifies Russia as an imminent danger
and China as the greatest long-term
threat
given president xi's comments Monday
that included threats to Taiwan
what should U.S policy be with China
moving forward from here
we've got to hold China accountable
we've got to hold them accountable for
the violations of our intellectual
property we've got to hold them
accountable for uh look the bottom line
is the United States is the world power
we're the most powerful nation in the
world China we know that China has not
been the best player the best actor and
we have to hold them accountable but
president she said about possibly taking
Taiwan by force that is totally against
our principles and our values and we
have to take action if there's any
serious effort to do that look I serve
on the intelligence committee as well as
the senator does that is something that
we have been monitoring
just about every day
if China makes any aggressive actions
deliberate actions to take Taiwan then
there has to be a response from the
United States Senator yeah first of all
I would say that every there's a fact
every major anti-china proposal that has
been voted on in the last five years
have been my bill so much so that China
has actually sanctioned and banned me
and I was very upset about that because
I had to cancel my vacation in Wuhan so
but all kidding aside
the 21st century will be different
defined by the relationship between the
United States and China we wasted 20
years thinking that once China got rich
and prosperous they would become like us
and we woke up into a world where they
don't want to become like us they want
to replace us
we made one mistake number one we
allowed American manufacturing to leave
this country and go to China and so
today they own the manufacturing
capacity 88 of pharmaceuticals come from
there so that's why I've worked on
things like bringing the pharmaceutical
industry back to the United States
particularly in Puerto Rico and I have a
bill that will do that the second thing
is we have to begin to invest in our
military particularly indo-pacific
region to defeat the weapon systems
they're innovating we don't need the
Pentagon spending all its time producing
videos on the proper use of pronouns we
need them focused on how to blow up
aircraft carriers
no teachers should ever be allowed to
teach
the audience but please respect the
candidates statements the bottom line is
we have to hold China accountable uh
there in your question involved their
takeover of Taiwan we have to make sure
that that does not happen and as a
member of the intelligence committee we
are that is an issue that we are
studying every day to make sure that
does not happen look the senator can
play
um
National Security expert all he wants I
know he needs that for his next
Presidential run congresswoman I need to
stop you there and I want to get because
you mentioned the senator another 30
seconds of the senator was yeah I mean I
don't know what she means I play
National Security yes but I'm the vice
chairman of the intelligence committee I
was the previous chairman of it so it's
actually my job
but
the second thing I would say yeah that
was cheap sheep flub that I think
holding China accountable that's that's
a talking point I get it I'm supporting
the concept it's a great Banner I'm sure
it's a good bumper sticker but it's not
a plan I actually have a detailed plan
for how you address it and one of the
things we have to do you want to hold
China accountable fix this country first
make things in America again because you
think things are bad now imagine the day
you wake up and realize we can't get
medicine because the Chinese have cut us
off
15 more seconds to the congressman
against the chip sack
he's goes around the state talking a lot
about our dependency on China
because of semiconductors
and then he voted against the chip sack
that would help for other America's
Independence and that is time for both
of you because you're going to get your
it's a gift full time for closing
statements Senator Rubio floor is yours
well thank you for hosting this debate
time glad people got a chance to see
that elections are about a choice
look I've been in Washington now for two
terms in the Senate and in the two terms
I've been there no U.S senator has
gotten more done than I have today
parents in Florida whose child have
pediatric cancer
will have options because I took on the
pharmaceutical companies and passed the
bill at four steps the child tax credit
double because I passed the bill that
did that veterans that had that were
exposed to toxic burn pits will now get
treatment at the VA and not have to
fight with the VA because we just passed
the bill that I sponsored all these
bipartisan to make that happen and
millions of American small businesses
and millions of Americans small business
jobs were saved because of the will we
passed and so I'm asking for a chance to
continue that work because I have a
record of not just identifying the
problems but fixing it and my opponent
has been in Congress now for half a
decade and has never passed a single
piece of legislation into law not one
the only thing she does is vote 100 with
Pelosi the vote is clear and I'm asking
voters for their support right on time
Senator congresswoman demings
thought I wasn't going to start my
closing arguments with the last couple
of things the senator said were just not
true and and let me say this I stand on
this stage tonight as a daughter
the daughter of a maid and a janitor
had the awesome honor of being the first
in my family to graduate college served
at the police department worked my way
up through the ranks to become the chief
of police serving in the house and now
running for the Senate only in America
is my story possible I just happen to
believe that every person regardless of
who they are deserves the opportunity to
succeed deserves the opportunity to make
it the senator will pick and choose
winners and losers based on their
ability to pay to play he talked about
pharmaceuticals he voted against
legislation that would help reduce the
cost of prescription drugs and help cap
the cost of insulin he's all sweaty yeah
that is time
that is time Senator Congressman thank
you both so much for participating in
this we want to thank our audience
across the State of Florida and on the
internet right now for this this will
also be broadcast rebroadcasted on
C-Span election day is November 8th and
early voting begins next week thanks for
watching we've got Rubio's trying to
space
wow all right folks listen uh a couple
stumbles for Val demmings but overall
a very solid performance will it matter
will Florida voters change four and a
half points which right now is what uh
it represents Marco Rubio's lead I don't
know I don't know but overall one of the
better performances I would say of the
midterms really really strong really
really strong uh if folks agree disagree
let me know in the chat let me know in
an email
etc etc
uh oh thank you to S Prez dumping in 18
subscriptions at the last moment to get
us to 100 and that is extremely
appreciated We are continuing to cover
debates almost daily please follow on
Twitch subscribe on YouTube and like on
Facebook all free all free and then you
will be notified when we go live with
the next debate which will be very very
soon is that what's going on here
hmm
the anchor seems confused something
weird's going on does she even
seems to have no idea what's going on
kind of an interesting interesting TV
moment but needless to say we will uh we
we were we'll let her do her thing thank
you for joining me everybody and we will
see you all very very soon